discuss the us election further now with
maria bhutan who joins me live in the
studio who's an arty russian host and
member of
russia's civic chamber thank you for
joining me in the studio this morning
maria donald trump's code advisor
recently appeared on our channel and
then apologized later for giving an
interview to a foreign agent
is there now a de facto censorship in
the us over where you can and can't
speak
well i don't know what is more
disgusting for me in this situation
on the one hand i understand him and the
reaction is so bad and
everybody's blaming you and he's afraid
to harm someone
so he start apologizing on the other
hand is it america where people
do not speak freely and when they do
they have to apologize
and they don't have enough strength like
as a man
to make a stand and say yes i said this
i did it
and so what so this is the weakness that
is formed by this censorship
and i think this is disgusting this is
not the united states we imagine
it to be and what i do believe
in the future it's not going to get
better
it seems that in that interview the
advisor made some
valid points is it dangerous that he's
not being allowed to speak freely
to who he wants even on health issues
that he's an expert in
absolutely this is what the the united
states of america based on their
constitution
and on the free speech but now just by
talking that he's talking not to the
person they like
and saying not the things they like
generally
they just start you know bullying media
bullying and this is what we see
he needs to apologize and take his words
back well this is very dangerous because
who decides what is normal and what is
abnormal to say
this is not good it's a huge week for
the united states
um and for all people around the world
their eyes are going to be trained on
what the outcome of this election will
be
but how much freedom do you think the
u.s president
has to change the country's course well
i'm a pessimist i don't think that the
president matters that much
because what we see is mostly like a
show so the whole world is watching
two candidates lead this very dirty
campaign you know they talk about
different personal issues not about
ideas not about the issues that do
matter for the country
but i don't think that the president
actually matters that much because we
saw
on obama on trump every president
every other president says that he wants
better relationships with russia
obama said that too and he actually made
certain steps to do that and what we see
nothing because i think this is not
there the president is not the key
figure and we are talking about big
money we are talking about military
complex
we are talking for those about these
people who are
actually interested to have wars and
conflicts because people who fear
russia or somebody else iran or china it
doesn't matter
people who fear they are easy to control
this is i think is the factor speaking
of little or no
change there's this obsession with
interference in american politics
what's it all about and is it ever going
to end well this is very interesting
because i was studying american
university cyber security issues
and it's so convenient to take a cyber
conflict
and make an attribution which is almost
impossible actually to do
and nobody can see it so you can claim
whatever you like
this is what they do they say well even
before something happens they already
start claiming that russia or china
iran is trying to break the elections
there is no elections yet
but they are still talking about it so i
think this is a dangerous thing because
you can mislead the public
and this is what they do why do why do
they do it because it's just you know
it's convenient
it's convenient for politicians so they
can blame somebody
for the mistakes that honestly are
inside
of the country they have a crisis of
elites republican
republicans and democrats and this is
what they should be focusing on
on their pandemic situation but instead
they try to take
the focus of public somewhere else and
this is very easy to say that enemy is
some
somewhere across the ocean somewhere
there
and make people scared and to control
them
i feel like almost every person i meet
no matter where they come from or where
they live they have a preference over
who they want to win in this election
how about people in russia how about
russia as a whole who
who would they prefer to win this
election you know i don't think that we
have any expectations this time
last time it was trump because he was
very vocal that he wants to restore
the relationships between the two
countries and
me too so i thought that there will be a
change
but you know we have so much
disappointment
in our soul now because look okay he
claimed a lot of things but at the very
end
every single day the situation gets
worse and russia now is an american
boogeyman
and russia russians today are the most
hated nation
in america and in the world so this is
not normal
and this is the the the world of hate
that actually
deorian the trump's term so i don't
think we have a preference because i
know and i absolutely support our
foreign minister lavrov who says that it
doesn't matter
what happened what russians do or they
don't because they're going to get
sanctioned
we're going to get hated anyway and this
is very sad because not
so long time ago we were in the war
in the horrible war where different
nation was hated
and we hope that we will never see
people divided by race or by nation
but in fact this is exactly what we see
today we've seen such
a significant rise in unrest and
division
in the you know across the united states
is all the current
u.s instability really that bad for the
rest of the world
yes it is i would call the united states
a spying
for the world because of course the
world economy
is still the us is still leading i mean
china somewhere close but still
and of course the turbulence the
instability
uh we're gonna see and we see it today
so whatever they have
or whatever russia has or whatever china
has meaning if
their country is a big player it's gonna
affect the world
and so i'm not sarcastic about what is
going on the united states now
though i could be like after what i
survived
i've been through in the united states
but i don't want to be because whatever
happens there
we're gonna see and this turbulence is
not good for the whole world
if you have somewhere an explosion
somewhere a conflict
it's bad because i like americans as
people and
having this conflict it really affects
us too
so i think i'm very sorry for the nation
because it's so disrupted now and so
it's in such a pain
of the problems they haven't solved for
years and they're this
that was my one of my first words when i
came back i said that's going to be a
crisis because
in the place i were in the jail i were i
saw what happens with black people
and they do have a reason for protest
um you mentioned you're a pessimist and
this might influence the answer to the
next question but do you expect much
change in the u.s after this election
unfortunately i don't
i think that the erusophobia the the
hate of russians
is going to continue because it's very
as i said convenient
to have somebody across the ocean to
hate and
i don't think that american politics is
going to be better because
every single campaign that we see it's
like the the last one in 2016
i was actually in the united states at
the time and what i saw was like
it was really dirty but now it's really
dirty on steroids
and i don't like that because
we they promote democracy they promote
the way of living
to other countries do we like this or
not it's a different question but they
do it
so this is the example they grant to
other countries
this is how everybody should live well
this is this is not the democracy
this is not the country where people
actually can even speak freely
so i don't think it's good and i do
expect that they're going to have a lot
of problems inside
and i hope that they're not going to get
to the civil war point
but i would expect this to happen wow
maria boutina thank you so much for
joining me in the studio this morning we
appreciate it